you
you
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon good afternoon and
welcome I asked you to please take your
seats at this time in a few minutes
the Graduate School procession will
enter from the rear of the auditorium
and will use both aisles if any
graduates have difficulty finding their
seats please ask an usher to help you
though as soon as you found them okay
thank you and congratulations
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
colleagues friends families and the 2017
graduates of Yale Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences
welcome to the 316th commencement of
Yale University and to the 100 56th
anniversary of the date on which Yale
conferred its first and the nation's
first PhD degree
today we celebrate your accomplishments
as scholars and researchers and we award
the degrees earned by your dedication to
the achieved advancement of human
knowledge we are proud of what you have
achieved in your time at Yale and we
thank you for your contributions to your
field congratulations to you all
to begin I want to recognize those
graduate students and faculty who
received prizes at yesterday's beautiful
convocation your programs list the
student academic prizes at this time I
ask all student Prize winners who are
here with us to stand so that we can
again congratulate you on your
achievements prize winners
and for the 17th time the graduate
mentor Awards celebrated faculty members
who have been outstanding teachers and
advisors of graduate students the three
faculty members who received the award
this year exemplify the many important
qualities to which all graduate teachers
should aspire I want to pause here to
thank the wonderful staff of the
University to whom we all owe much and
whose labor and loyalty contribute to
make Yale the distinguished University
it is several groups of Yale employees
beyond the faculty stand at the heart of
Yale the university's custodial and
maintenance staff make Yale look
beautiful and keep us in good condition
all year long
the dining hall staff feed us at
commencement and throughout the year the
clerical and technical staff conduct the
university's business with acumen and
dispatch and grace the managerial and
professional staff direct and administer
our departments and schools and
specifically the staff of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences sustains the
institution within which Yale educate
education thrives now for all these
wonderful women and men of Yale I asked
for a recognition through applause from
all of us
finally a special thank you to our
superb musical musical accompany us to
sitting down here mr. Nicholas core
Doukas one of the many accomplished
students at Yale institution Institute
of sacred music who is playing one of
the world's great pipe organs here in
Woolsey Hall
[Applause]
just a few words for you candidates for
the ph.d MPhil and master's degrees
before we begin the honor of conferring
your degrees I know for many of you
getting to this graduation day has not
been easy but your you have all
prevailed you have taken advantage of
all Yale graduate school offers in order
to pursue your studies and scholarly
research
Yale's rich academic environment has
emerged over 170 years of providing
students a place to experience the
intellectual freedom and joy of being
completely immersed in your chosen
discipline while also preparing you for
life after graduation and since in this
century since the year 2000 we've
provided full financial support for
doctoral education making it possible to
earn a PhD debt-free during your time
with us
during your time with us you have
learned the way of research and
scholarship is neither straight nor
smooth the line a line of inquiry could
take you nowhere and months of work may
bear no fruit an experiment could go
awry and you find yourself back at
square one it's happened to me I know it
does happen sometimes the work could be
lonely you don't need to be told that
graduate study takes inspiration but it
also takes hard work perseverance and
determination learning to continue in
the face of such challenges
characterizes the ability to do advanced
research and the fact that you sit here
today means you have learned that lesson
today you leave Yale as thinkers
explorers creators teachers and as many
of you heard at our at our recent where
do I go from Yale day you also leave
with a set of skills that equip you for
a variety of careers your innovative and
critical thinkers problem solvers
leaders team players and effective
communicators poised to launch
fulfilling careers whatever direction
you choose to apply your skills of
advanced learning let your
accomplishments here at Yale inspire you
to tackle new challenges with the
confidence that you have the skill to
navigate all difficulties as a Yale
graduate you are all given the
opportunity to contribute to society and
to make a difference in your field of
study so I hope that as alumni you will
stay engaged and in touch with us and
can consider mentoring those who follow
in your footsteps it has been my
privilege to lead the graduate schools
efforts to provide you with the
environment in which you grew into the
scholars you are today we will now award
the graduate degrees we will call the
graduates to the stage
by the department or program in which
they have earned their degrees for those
students receiving more than one degree
and we have a few all diplomas will be
awarded together
Dean Pamela my colleague Dean Pamela
sure Meister will read the citations
please come forward as your name is
called to congratulate the degree
recipients we will be joined at the
front of the stage by faculty members
from each department or program and yes
you may applaud as you see fit in former
times such applause for individual
graduates was thought impolite but we
welcome it now let us begin the awarding
of the individual degrees
oh no it's okay it's fine yeah thanks
for the PhD in african-american studies
[Music]
[Applause]
Julia burrell melanie Chambliss
Khaleel Anthony Johnson jr. Heather
Victoria vermeuhlen American Studies for
the PhD Michael Joseph amico
Sigma Cologne
[Applause]
Rebecca Hayes Jacobs
[Applause]
Michelle Morgan
[Applause]
Kaneesha shirelle parse our andrew
roberts seal Lauren Craig Tilton quand
tu a Tran
[Applause]
in anthropology for the PhD Sierra
Andrea bell jar galán brewing tug top
Erin Elizabeth Burke Peter Reid coot
rose
[Applause]
jessamy dolmen
[Applause]
Jamie Lee in would Ryan settle Jobson
[Applause]
Elizabeth Francis miles Jessica Marie
Newman
[Applause]
in Applied Mathematics for the PhD Chong
dang
[Applause]
womanly
[Music]
it applied physics for the PhD Raphael
Sarfatti
[Applause]
in archeological studies for the
master's degree Brandon Agosto
[Applause]
Chelsea Lee Kaufman
[Applause]
Benjamin thar dried out
[Applause]
in astronomy for the PhD ANOVA not so
[Applause]
john-michael brewer
Franko's yang
in cell biology for the PhD rui dong
[Applause]
rachel starr plum
[Applause]
RIF cook Schwartz
[Applause]
Margaret Kendall Willer
[Applause]
Nathan not neuen
in cellular and molecular physiology for
the PhD dubbed earth OD pong gauche in
chemistry for the PhD
Nadia corset a BOTS call Michaela circa
Candice and Baird chichén
saundra denise field darius Huang
[Applause]
Michelle Legaspi Hutchings
hiya jamali Patrick Robert Melvin
[Applause]
Anthony Joseph Mitrano Joey mikelis
[Applause]
Deacon James nem truck
[Applause]
Herman Nikolaev key
[Applause]
keek de Vries oddly
[Applause]
Jonah
Zachary bill sack Aaron's wicker and for
the master's degree
Alexander Paul para Beck for the PhD in
classics
Emily Houser you Kylie
[Applause]
Sean Patrick Northrup
[Applause]
in computational biology and
bioinformatics for the PhD
Christopher Andrew stuck Fragoso not xi
nage Jason Anthony Vander Heiden for the
master's degree dong hoon Lee
so Tom Lee
[Applause]
in computer science for the PhD wrong
way goo Debye in Gupta
[Applause]
he checked David lock Herman Patrick
patch coughs key
for the master's degree run by chi gong
tau chang-dong took me hang do fangirl
gun her
Changu GG goo
[Applause]
sakhu Jiang
eunbi charge in
[Applause]
remain COO
so now chang-jung you Shinya know
John ciao
changjun one she
chi'lan Sun Zi Jun Tong Siwon
ego one
sheeni one right alright so this person
might not be here we'll do that one
again
sheeni Wang yeah
[Applause]
song ji wen no does that
when you put them the one you put down
already
okay
usually I want she and shoe lucky young
[Applause]
and funshine
she ensue
[Applause]
Song Ji when in East Asian languages and
literatures for the PhD Stephen Frederic
Poland in East Asian Studies for the
master's degree you gents I
[Applause]
Amanda Shemesh
[Applause]
so fun
one ting go Gian goo
Conway hang
[Applause]
Lee Scott Lawrence
chin chin Lee calling Patrick Morshead
[Applause]
Helen Henning she which own son Nico
Te'o
[Applause]
in ecology and evolutionary biology for
the PhD
Benjamin Robert Evans
[Applause]
sarah Fetterman for the master's degree
Stacy and Arnold Larry Lee Bowman jr.
Michael Hanson
[Applause]
in economics for the PhD Gregory
Fletcher Cox
[Applause]
sharukh Ganapati
Matthew William grant Chiara margarita
[Music]
[Applause]
Kraig Paulsen
[Music]
[Applause]
Meredith Lindbergh starts how being
Wayne
[Applause]
Jeffrey Broadman Weaver
[Applause]
Jeffrey Feng Shang and for the master's
degree
Marianne brunettes Keiko Ellie Luis
Fabiano Carvalho Mateo
[Applause]
in the School of Engineering and Applied
Science for the PhD and Applied Physics
he had Lou for the PhD in biomedical
engineering Matthew Ryan Bercy Paulo de
aquila Yulin
Joseph Ryan for truly sure one
[Applause]
for the Masters of philosophy John
Treyarch for the master's degree you
fond Chen G Healy Xiao Xiao Li hallo
[Applause]
Xu Fei Liu
Rita Mata Kevin minta edrick town
[Applause]
she cashing in chemical and
environmental engineering for the PhD
Stacy and Cainan Jinyoung Lee Jung
Lindley Kyle Jacob more niveditha
Samudra la
[Applause]
[Music]
you fund uh this is for the master's
degree Abbie shake setta
[Applause]
you on John yo
[Applause]
in electrical engineering for the PhD
Lin Ron fan ho Jeong Jeong
[Applause]
Namrata ready the deer
[Applause]
Monica
Ursula Weber for the MPhil marathas
Lahey in mechanical engineering and
material science for the PhD divita
gyasi nathan john kemp ama Shobo duty
Chowdhury for the MPhil neelima sharma
[Music]
and for the master's degree Rodrigo
Miguel Ojeda Mota
[Applause]
in mechanical engineering for the PhD
Spencer be Bacchus
and Justin Tong
[Applause]
in English language and literature for
the PhD
Kimberly Kia gay Andrews Alexis Kate
Jemma
Robert Bradley Holden
[Applause]
Daniel Kyle jump Andrew McLean cow
[Applause]
Natalie vada Brazil
[Applause]
Rebecca Mira crush Prashant Sharma
[Applause]
Joseph Michael stood all neck
[Music]
[Applause]
Stephen Kirk Warner and for the Masters
Brittney Nicole Livingston
[Applause]
in European and Russian studies for the
master's degree
Daniel Robert Pitino Matthew Christopher
Dudley
Steven Richard Easley Colin Glen Hoke
Brendan Murphy
[Applause]
Chang knew John Robledo Paulo
[Applause]
max Jacob Schaffer Landau an
experimental pathology for the PhD
Deborah or be Amy
Haney Laura Elizabeth Stephens for the
MPhil pop by Wang
[Applause]
in film and media studies for the PhD
and Francis Bourke s Zelda Roland
right East aside ANOVA
[Applause]
in forestry and environmental studies
for the PhD Martin boda alder Kelemen
Saxena
[Applause]
run-run Wang
[Applause]
in French for the PhD Elizabeth ken-chan
Hubbard Laura be Jensen in genetics for
the PhD Elizabeth and junaid bacon John
Kenneth [ __ ] Lee
[Applause]
erin nicole hime
[Applause]
Richard W sorrow
[Applause]
daisies in
in geology and geophysics for the PhD
Jennifer and Axler Elizabeth Claire
crystallite
[Applause]
Daniel J field Emma Rose Locatelli
[Applause]
Hobart Patrick young
[Applause]
for the Masters of philosophy J Dane in
Germanic languages and literatures for
the PhD Joshua SL v zu Janet Daisy Buell
in history for the PhD
Catherines Stilwell Arnold
ACEF a shrub
[Applause]
Michael where hey Bustamante Nicole
Elizabeth cooing hing Sara IFFT Decker
[Applause]
Anna Cristina Graber
[Applause]
Michelle Claire Grizz a Michael David
Hatton evenly
Ryan ser patrique Oh
Joseph Warren Peterson Marco Ramos jr.
[Music]
[Applause]
alyssa is Archer right heart
Miranda Rogo socks
[Applause]
Sara Elizabeth lengua silverstein
well he'd bins yet and for the master's
degree
Jacob W McAuliffe in the history of art
for the PhD
Matthew Jeffrey Abrams
[Applause]
Carolyn Marie la fiere Steven mark
Laurita no Emma Natalya Stein
[Applause]
in immunology for the PhD ah su eridan
[Applause]
Jun Jie Gwang
[Applause]
Hachiko Hayashi
[Applause]
and for the Masters of philosophy
Vivian Yu Jing limb in the
interdepartmental neuroscience program
for the PhD
Emily Susanne Finn Colby are Keisler
[Applause]
William Jeffrey Larsen
[Applause]
Schenley
Robert James Wickham
[Applause]
and for the master's degree Kyla Davis
horn in international and development
economics for the master's degree
Garrett Medrano elf's tad Zahra
Ali may hair anon
Nina
Alva Bartman
[Applause]
Shriya Chandra we King Felicia achoo
Juba as equi silly
[Applause]
Patrick Greenfield Ravi shaaa Ravi Gupta
[Applause]
tong li Dana
Michelle Liske you Ching law
Paula marina Maloney Polly Marilyn otama
[Music]
[Applause]
Hiroyuki Natori suwari punish Nava Marie
Sophie polka
[Applause]
Krishna J Ramesh Sakshi Sethi Liang
Shuang Victoria song Preeti Sreenivasan
[Applause]
I'm son son Claire
Sophie Tavor let young and tong will pay
[Applause]
he'll NT on Anna Maria Trujillo Lamaze
[Applause]
Juliana Victoria visa when you are young
[Music]
[Applause]
done un true an investigative medicine
for the PhD
Christopher J Hammond
[Applause]
in Italian for the PhD Karen towba
raisin Kyle J Skinner in law for the PhD
Eric Studebaker fish
Ryan J Mitchell No
in linguistics for the PhD Leandra was
able anos
[Applause]
Lito n ma teak Sabina Maria Matty coup
[Applause]
for the master's degree Farook caucus
lead y'all in
for the PhD in linguistics
yayan lie
[Applause]
in management for the PhD Valentina
a a Sonova Naveed muggier beyond jooshin
[Applause]
Andrew Johnston Clare Rosanna Kim Smith
[Applause]
in mathematics for the PhD Veselin
dmitrov
[Applause]
Mac's cousin our airman
[Applause]
Chuck and couplets kailu one one
[Applause]
Liang Jiang
in Medieval Studies for the PhD
katherine storm Hindley
[Applause]
in microbiology for the PhD Lara
Juliette Kohler show to MA Jessica miles
[Applause]
in molecular biophysics and biochemistry
for the PhD dye Fei Liu David Richards
Ashley Colleen Schloss Jessica Marie Wiz
are for the master's degree Jeremiah
David Johnston
[Applause]
in molecular cellular and developmental
biology for the PhD Edward Barbieri Alan
long Zhao
Stacy
Alicia Lawrence jewelry park
[Applause]
in music for the PhD Stewart Paul Duncan
[Applause]
Daniel Lawrence Goldberg
[Applause]
Andrew Daniel Jones
Cara you layman to her a Mota's edn
[Applause]
Rebecca Perry
Kamala Jacobs shelling
[Applause]
in your Eastern languages and
civilizations for the PhD Elizabeth
Wilson Lang Shana Sarah Zaya
[Music]
in neuroscience for the PhD when dr chow
[Applause]
in nursing for the PhD patient Chang
[Applause]
Samantha Conley
[Applause]
Shelly el fader show wrong Park
[Applause]
in pharmacology for the PhD Alison Beth
Goldberg Andreea Christine massage for
the Masters of philosophy Molly Ryan
[Applause]
in physics for the PhD Victor Albert
[Applause]
Marco dehiscence bonnet Matisse
[Applause]
Minna dawn
Alexandra bug den Georgescu
[Applause]
hey you on now
[Applause]
so Hansel Oh
[Applause]
Toshihiko shimazaki
- mommy soon Yama Mitchell James
Underwood the third with masters of
philosophy taneema Tasnim Anana Shawnee
Daniela
[Applause]
Christopher James Davis Andrew David
Gasparo
James Alan Ingleby Meredith Clark Powell
in political science for the PhD ooh
more bash - Joshua Stanton braver
Suparna Chowdhury step on ice
Jumanji fair hard onon Natasha your cave
X G Jung ko Gareth Hugh Bernard Nellis
[Applause]
Pia Joanna RAF ler
[Applause]
Stephen Carl Rosen's wide Neil offer
Amina Siddiqui Michael Weaver for the
Masters of philosophy Clara picker
[Music]
Alicia Marie Steinmetz
[Music]
[Applause]
and for the master's degree Konstantin
Munda in psychology for the PhD Hilary
Chapman Devlin Lindsey Arlene Brayton
[Applause]
Matthew Fisher
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
danielle marie Gerhart Alena Carmen hey
[Applause]
Samuel Gregory Blaine Johnson Monica
dawn Rosenberg Lauren K Ruth Rebecca and
Vanden ho nerd victoria lynn web and for
the master's degree iman long
[Applause]
in public health for the PhD Alexander
raised a bizarre Z
[Applause]
Robin Arcadia cream Elise grace Elliot
[Applause]
Zi Xuan foo
[Applause]
Gregg Steven Gonzalez
[Applause]
Catherine Patricia hacker
you know SWAT Leon hurts to cut Lee
[Applause]
Joseph August Lonard tianchu
[Applause]
Cheon XI Lu
let's say for Lynn Martinez
Steven Michael mcLaughlin
[Music]
Erica Murray Rogen
[Music]
Veronica Siobhan OVA Samantha accent
striker
[Applause]
do you want hoon
[Applause]
for the master's degree Alexander
Theodore B Megan Catherine Carol when
Jane come
[Applause]
Jenny Jung Lee
[Applause]
bo yang Lee
[Applause]
mauricio Fernando Pinilla you Zhang
Jiang in religious studies for the PhD
Andrew Charles Forsythe simcha Menachem
gross
[Music]
[Applause]
Matthew David Larsen
[Applause]
Rahel Leah Ross shiner men
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Daniel sue Shriver
Olivia Katharine Stewart Lester in
Renaissance studies for the PhD Leonard
Vincent mailings
[Applause]
Matthew Stephen Tenneco
[Applause]
in Slavic languages and literatures for
the PhD for Brazil Pengy Thomas F Kenan
[Applause]
Nicolette Scylla ku Penske
[Applause]
Michaela mikhailova
[Applause]
for the master's degree on your quark
[Applause]
in sociology for the PhD Sara Shoshana
bass Tomsky Mira see deaths Jonathan
Charles andleman John Patrick Hartley
[Applause]
Angela Fe OMA on Watchi Willie Kristen
Victoria magistral e+
[Applause]
in Spanish and Portuguese for the PhD
Maria Gracia Rios
[Applause]
Jose Antonio Simonet Leon
in statistics for the PhD rashaam
[Applause]
for the master's degree
Shing guru Chen
[Applause]
he by Chen
[Applause]
Shaylee as Rooney
[Applause]
Jonathan Rogers Harris
[Applause]
Seungyeon Wang
[Applause]
one Jang
[Applause]
nanquan
homie Ollie
[Applause]
Lind really
[Applause]
blue lonely
[Applause]
growing u-z pan
[Applause]
each one
[Applause]
sure if a young
so I want to thank Dean sure Meister for
reading all those names thank you
and now I'm going to ask as I call out
each degree for the recipients of that
degree that you stand and remain
standing after which I'll ask everyone
to congratulate all our graduates
together for their marvelous
achievements please remain standing to
the end Master of Arts stand master of
science Stan Master of Philosophy Doctor
of Philosophy
you
okay
graduates please remain standing it's
become the tradition in the Graduate
School to recognize that the commitment
of time effort and attention required to
achieve an advanced degree is only
possible with the participation and
support of our families and friends
therefore I ask I invite you all of our
degree recipients to turn and
acknowledge the support they have
received in the achievement we are
celebrating here together
have a seat graduates friends families
together with the faculty and staff who
are with us you are all invited to a
picnic lunch immediately following the
ceremony in the courtyard and common
room of the MacDougall Center in the
Hall of Graduate Studies please join us
now I ask you to remain in your seats
while the platform party recesses from
the auditorium and we ask that you exit
from the main rotunda on on my right
actually I think it's that way the two
exit doors on College Street will be
opened once the stage is cleared after
you exit you should after you exit
Willie will see you you should proceed
to HDS via the College College on Wall
Streets the Grove Street sidewalks are
too narrow for such a large group and we
don't want to block traffic so there'll
be people outside to direct your
attention finally congratulations to
each and every one of you we are very
proud of all you've achieved
you